joining us now is Texas democratic
Congressman Henry choir and sir thank
you for your time on this Sunday
thank you Bill I want you to listen to a
Democratic mayor in Eagle Pass Texas
Orlando Salinas is his name on President
Biden's policies
I'll be honest with you I believe 100 he
does bear some responsibility for this
crisis I haven't heard from anybody in
the administration the president hasn't
put out of the state a statement the
vice president I haven't heard from
anybody sir you're a Democrat why is
that Democratic mayor such a lonely
voice
you know some of us along the border
have been talking about what's been
happening on the border for many years
look you know what we need to do is to
do this one we need to have
repercussions at the border what does
that mean you got to deport people and
you got to show those images of people
being deported what was the last time we
saw people going the other way instead
of just seeing people flow in and the
second thing is keep in mind what
happened in 2015 what happened in 2019
under President Trump President Obama
and what I think happened a couple of
days ago but now we got to see the
enforcement we got to get Mexico to do
more like they did in 2019 like they did
in 2015 and hopefully they the agreement
they reached a couple days ago with the
administration and that is get the
people on the Mexican side Deport them
to their countries do more to stop
people in the on their southern border
with Guatemala otherwise we're just
going to continue seeing this flow it
worked in 2015 under Obama it worked
under President Trump and now if this
agreement that got reached a couple days
ago if they enforce it correctly then we
should see a a slower enough of a flow
of people coming in all right President
Biden did set in motion of following
things uh this past week a few of them
he granted work visas to 400 000
Venezuelans he assigned 800 U.S military
members to work in Border offices uh
secretary mayorkas met with the
president of Honduras over the weekend
of the Border does any of that sir
change the current human tide
well again it does provide some
assistance but if look if you talk about
those work visas without doing anything
else I mean the work uh permits without
doing something at the border then it
becomes a magnet there's there are
several things you need to do I still
say this and I've been saying this for
years we as Democrats and Republicans
can continue playing defense on a
one-yard line or we can play defense on
their 20-yard lines and that is getting
Mexico to do more like they did in 2015
when the numbers started slowing down
2019 where the numbers are slowed down
and if we do it then it's going to
happen we need to stop playing defense
you can send more National Guard you can
send more active members you can add
more but think about what they do think
about the images you saw there what
happens when they get the Border once
they touch the riverbank they can claim
Asylum and we know that 89 to 90 percent
of them don't even qualify for us on an
NFL Sunday perhaps that is a proper
metaphor Donald Trump tried to build a
wall
President Biden said the root causes
need to be addressed in Central America
and Kamala Harris has put in charge of
that as you know just this morning we
have this ABC Washington Post pull out
shows only 23 percent of Americans
approve of Biden's handling on
immigration a brutal 62 percent
disapprove we are almost three years
into this Administration
why did it get this bad
you know the policies that you have in
place uh it doesn't matter what
administration uh you got to have
policies that have repercussions if you
don't have repercussions then people
will see the Border as a speed bump and
continue coming in so again I think
Trump went too much to the right by
doing the um uh the separation of
families and kids and then I think uh
President Biden the administration is is
not doing enough so we got to find the
right balance you got to listen to the
community leaders like the mayor of uh
Eagle Pass the mayor of El Paso and
other places they got to listen to
communities at the borders and again one
you have repercussions at the border
that is you Deport people that are not
supposed to be here number two uh you
got to play defense on the other uh
20-yard line and it's very important it
you know people give credit to president
Trump but if you look at it it was
Mexico doing a lot lot more just like
they did in 2015 2015 2019 hopefully
this year Congressman Cuellar I
appreciate your time thank you sir for
joining us hi everyone I'm Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now